there was no specific area we wanted to
you could go after it was about you know
the economic conditions for us as I
should say a big 8 great
I believe employer here in the UK we
have 15,000 people working for our
customers in Siemens on 14 min of actual
size they're just about to complete our
our Peak investment up in hallways more
than 300 million pounds which we have
been investing in the UK truly is the
you know one of the centerpieces of
renewable energies if it comes to
offshore wind we see that it was
important that we understand you know
what economic policy is going forward on
renewable so it was an exchange about
opportunities and obviously
prerequisites which need to be taken
into account to allocate resources also
to the UK which has been important
because it's the it's the largest
European Stephens country outside
Germany Siemens is clearly a joint
global company how would you view
restrictions on the movement of labour
you know the UK is as important to us
than any other country in a way if it
comes to our employees and to our
customers so therefore of course we it
really would really support the notion
that there is free movement of people we
truly support the notion that there is
free movements of goods and services
like free trade free and fair trade
absolutely and I mean obviously if you
look at the letter of which has been you
know hand it over
it's been an explicit will from the
Prime Minister and the British
government you know about free trade
it's been explicitly all about a close
relationship in cooperation between you
know all the countries and the economies
in the world however I think it also
fair to assume that it naturally cannot
be as good as it could have been in a
world where you give and take
so the question is what will be the
giving and the taking
Simmons is a big investor being employer
in the UK what commitment can you give
today about future investment about two
weeks after the vote of the British
people I took my whole managing board to
come over to the UK we did go to our
customers we did go to you know the
House of Commons we did visit people at
business partners our employees and said
look we are here to stay they're going
to continue to serve our customers we
are not making our customer service
dependent on you know on on political
movements which you know need to be
straightened out so we are a reliable
partner
and nothing has really changed since
then and so far I have to say we've been
well advised to do exactly this